marketing is the biggest driver to
business results in the world sales is
amazing and I love being a Salesman but
sales is just bad marketing marketing
is the most important thing in the world
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documentary
[Music]
every day
people complain about silly small things
being upset about the most minute things
complaining
jealous Envy will be some insecurity and
then
when I say to a lot of those people that
I'm close to like one day you're gonna
have something to actually be upset
about
yesterday
a senseless act took the life of a
friend of mine and just made me think
like on this morning walk talk like
today may have some challenges that's
just a human life Journey
please put things in perspective
save your anger
anger and unhappiness for the big things
start practicing whether it's meditation
or positive positive people around you
or extra something just practice
how to let the mundane everyday things
roll off your back I saw somebody
yesterday lose her [ __ ] mind that
somebody cut them off in traffic
people are losing their lives
people get terminally ill There's real
serious [ __ ] out here
don't be upset about dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
hey yeah crib only some Heaven I've been
feeling
the reason I want 15 year olds to garage
sale is first I want more 15 year olds
to stand on their own two feet and buy
things with their own money not their
parents money because that will lead to
a lot of Happiness number two garage
sailing teaches a lot of things it
teaches work ethic because if you're
going to get the good stuff you got to
wake up at 6 a.m it teaches marketing if
you want your stuff to sell on eBay
you're gonna have to know how to title
it and how to write the copy and how to
put a picture and if you're going to
want to make that transaction you're
gonna have to pack it and go to the post
office and do all this stuff and I'm a
very big fan of garage sale flipping as
a foundation of teaching retail jobs
where you deal with a lot of people or
garage sale jobs where you're learning a
lot of different skills
[Music]
already committed
[Music]
screams fill up them jeans raised around
functioning things they're such a
customer I haven't I haven't yet I
haven't reviewed it I'll find it on this
plate
and
black I got like six pairs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all of your two cents every day you can
text call
um is gotta analyze everything we've
been doing and figure out what we're
doing that's a good use of time and not
a good use of time that's our that's our
biggest problem slash opportunity you
know I mean this is what we do for a
living like what I do for a living for
it to matter you have to do it on social
media organic and it has to pop back to
everybody did a wine show after I did it
but it didn't mean anything because it
because it's not the show it's the
content and more importantly what people
want on text is very different than what
they want on social or email the
platform that's Distributing something
is a very big variable into how somebody
consumes it and what they do with it
woke up feeling no refresh how are
things Adam SME how's uh Nadler and wine
rep Dylan they're doing right
they are doing well
they're the looks they're not the Brain
Trust
[Music]
haters
homie never ever let them tell you who
you are yeah most folks do not want to
see you win got rich just so I could say
I did Sidetrack but you know I'm right
back on self-care each and every day I
live I got time today you was talking
[ __ ] I'm outside please welcome to the
stage Gary vaynerchuk
I come here this afternoon as a very
practical dude that's been doing this a
long time how many people here
consume content on LinkedIn go into
LinkedIn they're active raise your hand
all right so this is way [ __ ] better
than I thought
so the far majority of this room
understands at least from a personal
human being standpoint that they're
consuming information on LinkedIn which
then renders all of you to completely
follow what I'm saying which is 98 of it
is garbage and it's garbage because
almost every single person that creates
LinkedIn content comes from the
perspective of sales DNA often people
are very passionate about putting in the
work at their craft but they don't want
to put in the work on things that don't
come easy or they don't understand I'm
incredibly aware that marketing is a
very different skill set than a core
craft that is sitting in this room I
also want to remind everybody that
marketing is the biggest driver to
business results in the world that sales
is amazing and I love being a Salesman
but sales is just bad marketing
marketing
is the most important thing in the world
thank you
how many people here have a tick tock
raise your hand like consume tick tock
wow wait less than I thought actually
um so for the people in here use
hashtags of some of the words in your
world and take a look there's like a lot
more how-to videos from this sector
being done there's some people making
paper
by getting clients from Tick Tock a
behind the scenes stuff is crazy it's
it's very real it's the same old game I
don't understand how so few hands went
up more people just keep making the same
mistake the same people that didn't get
on that didn't raise their hands to get
on Tick Tock also didn't get on Facebook
because they thought it was a kid thing
and everybody here knows Facebook in 15
years went from college kids to grandmas
and so these things grow like a
restaurant like a nightclub they mature
differently and I'm just shocked that
people's audacity to think their
personal opinion is a good business
strategy
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you for having me Sophie why would
we not do a selfie there we go
[Music]
there is no such thing as work-life
balance there's just your real life
so you know it exit blows somebody comes
along and says I have a million dollar
piece of business for you
but you're gonna you and but you're
gonna have to grind for three weeks
you're gonna over communicate to your
partner and be like look this changes a
lot of things but then on the other side
of it you're like okay maybe take an
extra weekend or you know what I mean
yeah you just gotta live normal life
instead of some weird ideology this is
where School [ __ ] up everybody School
makes people think there's actually some
rule for work-life balance work-life
balance is different for every
individual Partners on Earth yeah
thank you appreciate it thank you what
ends up working for me is like people
people are like nice nice killers right
like yeah I get that you want to work
for a killer but if that person's like
degrading you they're like right like so
but listen I'm also aware that it's not
super easy to find like a [ __ ] nice
assassin you know what I mean which is
why like I keep trying to tell people
I'm like a lot of these kids they start
actually being nice people and they
think to be [ __ ] a trillionaire they
gotta be a dick right which is why I'm
like so motivated to put out my content
I'm like look I'm gonna be [ __ ] the
number one guy and be the nicest guy and
so can you so what the [ __ ] are we doing
here and I think you know when you bring
those guys up like it was funny where my
brain went I'm like that's what's
happening people [ __ ] see they're
like [ __ ] am I you know and then you
know what happens it gets into their
head and then one Thursday they get
yelled out for some dumb [ __ ] and
they're like [ __ ] this
right that's life that's the [ __ ]
game yeah
it's a done deal I love it how in
Colorado hit the lotto got a cabin in
the middle of the mountain [ __ ] I feel
like I'm the man now I'm just leaving DC
grateful grateful grateful grateful even
in a rough patch imma always make do
even when I'm down bad I'll be saying
thank you even when I'm well sad I could
never hate you now get up and I get it
on the worst day
self-care [ __ ] that's the first thing
grind to you chilling on a work day and
when you get it I hope you are grateful
grateful grateful grateful yeah yeah
thank you for my Noah's Ark that's worth
the blue the deep blue sea can't [ __ ]
with me one day back in the action some
office time in the early day quick
helicopter ride to DC and back gave a
keynote caught up on a ton of work I
find myself very productive about to go
do a workout
and then going out for uh a couple of
more uh two or three more dinner
meetings so in the grind the daily B I
love you I love you all
see you next time
[Music]